so you're probably my favorite guests to
have on every time when I do on the show
had your winners Wednesday you've done
some some stuff and people always I have
Amanda back on the show so what have you
been up to I've been up to you oh my
gosh life with the kids
I've been going on training courses for
personal development for myself and I've
also been getting more involved with the
big development stuff now with Ben we're
checking anger so lots of exciting stuff
going up honestly think I mean people
say this to me all the time they
genuinely say that I'm just the luckiest
person to have you as a wife so what's
it like number one being married to me
because obviously that's like a
full-time thing in and of itself yeah
number two being a mom and number three
working hard cuz you do a lot on the
property side on the development and not
only on the big development side but
also just managing and overseeing some
of our residential site as well yeah so
what what's that like and how do you
manage everything from the time and
stuff like that what's it like oh my
gosh
it's exciting and busy I never you tell
them yes when I have a youtube channel
so crazy leads yeah and so yeah so it's
an it's all exciting busy I think I sort
of have to be a bit attentive to you so
whenever you're home I try to make sure
that I'm not busy with other things
because you're really really busy so
what do you attentive to me is in like
give words of affection give you give
you my all in your home because you're
always like when you're out you're on
the go you're busy and then when you get
home the last thing you want I'm not
gonna be armed just filming my view Tube
channel when you get home you are free
yeah I'm free for you drop stuff yeah so
I just I managed my time by just making
sure that I just kind of get up to
whatever I want to do the day what's
your favorite thing to focus on out of
all the different things you do what's
the most exciting most exciting I love
my me time I love reading you have been
on your own as well I love being on my
own because you're you're an extroverted
introvert
yeah in terms of if we go to a part of
your life and soul of the party yeah I'm
one of the reasons I fell in love with
you was because you're just so out there
I remember the like that video of you
and the girls in Barcelona where you
were literally dancing on the train to
Beyonce people on the train and I
thought that girl doesn't care what
anybody thinks
which is a great witch right but then
also you love being on your own yeah
having you time and sometimes in the
house jamendo who was it that came and
our house and they were like I know yeah
yeah it was my mom actually was one
weekend my mum came and we don't that
long but we sometimes we don't even talk
yeah we'll be in the same room but just
you're playing a book over here yeah or
you'll be just doing bit of housework
and I'll just be quietly on my laptop
when they say we want to talk for three
hours but at other times we just stay up
till 3:00 in the morning am I crazy
chain we've got people over the house is
forwards like like this morning I had my
personal trainer here it's a madhouse
and we bring people over all the time
we've had we have guests over the house
it's kind of like a madhouse but what
would you say the the the thing that you
really enjoy the most is well I just
said I love spending I love spending
time with myself because it is it can be
quite busy I think yes and stuff and
then obviously spending time with you
other when we go away and we go yeah and
people say to me as well sometimes you
know how do you find time to be with
Amanda we spend a lot of time - oh dear
like a lot of time together yeah I
probably spend more time of you than
anybody I would say here's the thing
with other people it goes through
seasons so I'll go through a season of
seeing Russell loads I'll go through
seasoning emelian loads I go through
season of seeing whoever but with you
it's just consistent yeah so over a
one-month period I might see Russell
Moore but then if you
over a year period as always I know
because some people ask me like Oh
Samuels always so busy all you need to
tell Samuel to slow down and I think
people's perception is that you're
hardly ever really home and you like
always busy working and stuff but you
are quite a family man and I think a lot
of people I mean they know that you are
but I don't think we truly quite believe
that you Spencer you do Spence like lots
of time at home and with me sir yeah you
are a family man and you are around a
lot I'm learning a lot if I'm tired if I
if it's like going to the office
tomorrow I just won't go yeah and then
we just have a family day yeah yeah at
the office family day but I don't have
that feeling very often ya know because
you do love what you do you love I think
you buzz off being in the office and
being with your clients and stuff sir
yeah have you got out that tell me
because we've not even caught up
properly how did you get over the castle
yesterday castle is good so I went to
the castle yesterday and check in on
progress and I've decided I'm gonna go
every month now but whatever and Ben's
there doing a site meeting and it
progressed in some ways then also I
think because it's kind of been stripped
back there's lots of work to be done I
always see the workmen yeah I can see
yeah yeah I know
it was like all overgrown cobwebs it was
like a bit gross dingy and dark now it's
like really light is you've got one half
of it which is just like literally if
you just refurb it and it'd be done good
to go and then one side is really really
damaged and I think that's where the
roof had like needed repairs and stuff
so it's completely stripped back at the
moment because I think what people don't
understand is that like the painting and
decorating that and the interiors that's
the easy part
ah yeah when when you start decorating
it and put in the bathroom that means in
a few months
yeah the stuff that takes time is all
the other stuff like dealing with all
the licensing so much to consider but
yeah the bat so at the moment they've
got the roofs off and they're doing
there's lots of
like rotten Timbers and stuff from the
roofs for having to replace all of that
but once that's all replaced they have
to have it ready by I think April so
that the bats can be rehoused and have
to build some bat houses and stuff
because the protected species would at
that time yeah yeah Ben's on it yeah
yeah it's really interesting because for
me as well like for me when I bought the
castle that was a me stretching out of
my composition can you see me on top it
was a project but for you actually
professionally the castles are small
yeah yeah yeah professionally yeah I've
seen I've seen worse I've seen bigger
and yeah you've you've had clients like
you word for coca-cola yeah and just
like one of their factories needed em
refurb so it's it's it's massive so it
was just like one section where I had to
ask you what I had to do a cost planned
for how much the works gonna cost so
measure everything and then see how much
give them an idea of how much it's gonna
cost to do the works yeah and then once
that was done we had to send out the
tenders the work for tender so you have
different contractors like three or four
contracts that will cost the works so
they will provide an estimate of how
much it's going to cost and then I would
then I had to produce the cost report
attend a report for reporting back to
the client controller how much it was
you know how much everyone quoted and
then we and then based on what I provide
them then they make the decision on
which contractors they're gonna choose
to do the works and then going forward
after that and pre pre contract then
post contract its managing and the
content of the contractor doing the
works and making sure that they're
staying within the contract so that was
agreed and we're driving around leaves
or every other like I worked on that
project yeah that's what I love about so
I love about property and I'll say into
the Builder yesterday at the castle was
like oh my gosh forever you're going to
be able to say you worked on restoring
this building and making it you know
amazing again and I love that I love
being able to pluck oh my gosh I I cost
of that or I worked on that and it's
yeah how do you feel what's your you add
some
nightmares with managing tenants last
year yeah oh my gosh yeah to the point
where you were just like you know what
son you here because I we have some
lovely tenants but I think with this one
it was HM er and I kind of thought oh
I'll just deal with it because at the
time I was just like ah I hadn't been in
property I sort of liked since having
kids I'd sort of step back a bit and I
thought ah I'll just deal with the
tenants I know the tenants cool fine and
it was just before we went to Uganda I
had a bit of a nightmare with suppliers
to the person that was going to be doing
the carpet recapturing the house and
stuff and yeah it was the thing it's
really funny because it's so funny when
I hear like tenants complaining to the
management companies about how awful you
are no nicest person ever I feel like
I'm the nicest person to deal with and
I'm so reasonable so for someone to like
say that I'm right and you're not like
oh very sweet yeah yeah you know so when
I see the tenants complaining about you
to the management company the funniest
is when people don't know that you're my
wife
yeah and then they'll send me a message
and this has happened where they're like
there's like they have no I have no idea
we just went into units like oh yeah the
you're my wife but it's crazy though and
I think I post it on Facebook the other
day that if you have enough tenants you
need to expect at some point you're
going to be the bad guy and someone's in
someone's story yeah it's good you just
know that some of these testing to be
there and their family gonna be around
you know don't and they're gonna be
going yeah terrible by their version of
events yeah you're gonna be the bad guys
yeah and I think that experience it just
it made me realize that I definitely
didn't want to personally deal with
tenants anymore I was just that I've
done it a lot I've got so much
experience to do in it but I think now
because of like being a mom and stuff
initially I thought uh when I was
pregnant I thought oh my gosh I want to
be a stay-at-home mom full-time and
how's that but I had the the option to
do that and I've done that now for two
years and it's amazing but now I'm
thinking that other you know there's
more to me than just being a mom yeah
and I love property so I've thought okay
well I want to get involved in property
and now know that I don't want to have
to like the nitty-gritty dealing with
tenants and stuff and I think now the
property development side of things
that's really good because it gives me
the freedom to still do property but
also the flexibility I can work around
the kids like I've got so yesterday I
was at the castle in the week I have
like playgroup with the kids swimming
with the kids and stuff but with with
the property development side because
it's sort of like you can have a project
and it's ongoing
you just sort of I can go to site
whenever I want dip in and out and just
you know be on the phone with people so
I think sure it's always like you are
working alongside band yeah so from
Ben's position it's full-on yeah
everyone doesn't know that Ben's the
property director and he's your brother
yeah but he's got 16 years and industry
is chartered surveyor yeah he's great so
I've taken him on to partner with some
of the deals and he's doing a great job
but you feel like you're an unfortunate
situation video because you're you've
got the luxury have been able to work on
the sites and stuff but then you haven't
got the necessarily the full weight yeah
that's ability for it to all be on your
head
you almost I wouldn't say Ben's
assisting because that might be able
most a little bit of a dish on you
because you're not you know you're doing
you're doing high level stuff but you
almost take out work yeah I've got the
best of both worlds which was really
cool that yesterday we went to the
castle with Ben but all on the journey
there on the journey back we were like
looking for sighs yeah appraising
properties and stuff so I was just there
working whilst he was driving it
just cool well you just got yourself as
a powerful person yeah I think so and I
think some people some people sometimes
ask me it sometimes and it always seems
like they pity me a bit and they're like
ah so Samuels got you know what he does
and the training business and that you
know he's into property the stuff in you
know do you want to do something for you
and I'm like it almost as if like oh
it's all about Samuel and I'm just like
the little submissive wife that just
goes on with what you do but I don't
think so I think there's a lot of power
in being a supportive wife and
supporting you in what you do and I
think it just because I'm like a
supportive wife because I think our
roles are quite traditional in that you
go out you work you bring in a lot of
money and I'm at home my main
responsibilities and what I want is
looking after the home and looking after
the kids but I think being so supportive
for you I think I'm a great asset to you
because if I gave you hell you'll be
able to be so focused on or even yeah
yeah yeah if you gave me nothing
yeah I wouldn't be hot on behalf I
wouldn't have half the business yeah you
know yes not only do you not make my
life difficult but also and make my life
easy but also help on that like for me
it's massive yeah and I don't know many
successful successful people that have
built large businesses where they
haven't had powerful people around them
yeah you know yeah I think you're
powerful you're powerful person and I
think that you're strong person and I
love doing business with you and I lived
in life with you and we also go on
holiday a lot we go to exotic holidays
at least sometimes three four yeah I
mean I think we're going away four times
this year yeah just somewhere beautiful
where well where we go next door where
you're most excited about well we're
gonna do a little break in Paris
I know I know and my toes in bobwhite
yeah
say Bobbo be good yeah good you born and
bred in Zimbabwe gonna bet I know some
people like don't don't realize maybe I
don't put it out there you know that I
Bob Wian that's true yeah I did a Q&A on
my Instagram recently and someone said
like is it true that you're from
Zimbabwe and I was like yeah yeah born
and bred I was born in Zimbabwe moved to
England when I was ten years old so I've
spent well it's it's less than half my
life now but yeah I spent a lot of my
involvement yeah and you've got British
citizenship now yeah cuz on your to do
this problem yes on my to-do list it's
actually coming up to a year you know
two year anniversary this is really came
British yeah Congrats
thank you so fast what about that time
when you thought that I thought that you
wanted to marry me to be compression and
no oh my gosh that was so awkward you'd
so I was Zimbabwean I had an indefinite
right to stay in the UK so I could I
could live here forever
yeah and I just had this involving
passport and you asked me to go to
Ireland Dublin Southern Ireland
yes of an island so obviously Northern
Ireland is part of the UK so because we
haven't been dating that long
no we had a me day in that long and so
to go to southern island I'd need a visa
because it's not part of the UK and
that's like the conrod that's involving
passport you need a visa to go anywhere
so I was like oh so you said hey let's
go to Turtle Island and I was like oh I
thought and it was on text message and I
thought oh oh we have to tell him now so
I said you like a long essay that took
me forever to like write up explaining
why it was like oh I need to get a visa
and I didn't think you'd even understand
it I was like oh my gosh and what did
you say you said to me so I thought so
then I sent you the message then I
thought you you just be like I think I
took a long time to respond yeah
you thought it was like an issue yeah
but I'm well covered and I get it yeah
yeah so I thought that you just think oh
my gosh maybe she wants to be with me
because she wants to get she wants to
get a stay in the UK or something but
what about people say that are the only
reason Samuel you're with such a
beautiful heart intelligent attractive
woman is because of your money I know
please do not offend me people with like
comments like that people that bike say
or or must be with him for the money
like no that is just so not the case
well firstly firstly that's how you
about the money yeah when we when we
started dating and we didn't have any
mutual friends and I was literally I
just finished three years of Bible
College at the time and I was focusing
heavily on the charity on the training
Kings which was a non-profit yeah so I
wasn't even out there yeah tell you
secondly I didn't have anywhere near the
wealth that I have now we've been
married now five years woman no over
five years when we had our when we had
the African wedding when so when we met
I was 23
yeah and yes I was financially free and
yes I was doing all right I wasn't even
a millionaire then I become a
millionaire 25 thanks to you yeah like
now multi-millionaire again thanks to
you so it's just like yeah people I
think I think people just love to say
things like that because it may be maybe
listen if it helps them it's obviously
not in fact I told you that I was in
debt I was I tried to scare you off by
tell you how much debt I've got and you
like it's fine
maybe I can get an extra job because
extra hours yeah so it's just like when
people save some comments I just think
they just obviously don't know us at all
cuz anyone that knows us just knows what
we like yeah so what's next then what's
the plan for you what are you gonna
really focus on this year this year I
want to focus on building my brand as
Amanda Leeds I think I want to inspire
lots of ladies out there yeah maybe
there's some people as well like females
Molly
the property couldn't quite relate to me
but then you know the same stuff you
know just a properties I know about
property so yeah you've got the
knowledge you've built the business with
me to a large extent so I think I think
it's great what you're doing on YouTube
and you share it a different way but all
the way over like like the three steps
to get whereas you you're just like the
man who's there in the back different
vibe you give off but I think that's
okay why do you want to inspire people
to moms and women to do property because
I think I've seen I've seen what you do
and like when we go to like the winners
the winners dinners were all over the
Academy members and I see so many people
that oh my gosh I'm financially free
because EMT training it's the fun like
oh my gosh that's so cool so many
people's lives have been changed and I
think some people like they might think
oh my gosh I'm not really in a position
where I can do that like as a female and
yeah they might not relate to you but I
think if I can just inspire so that's
why I think doing my YouTube videos
which is just like kind of vlog style
come with me kind of see what I do see
what you know see what happens I think
it's just a different way of sharing and
I think some people might
I don't know respond to that more and
ultimately it's just the same mission of
just helping people yeah which I'm
passionate about giving the people to
the freedom to live the lives that they
want as well as having the the
flexibility of you know doing whatever
they choose yeah I mean do you think do
you think you have to be a property
full-time what do you think you can get
started part-time I think you can do it
part-time I don't I don't think you have
to be full-on I mean there's people I
mean there was the lady on your winners
on a Wednesday who's got a nine-to-five
job and she's earning what three three
thousand a month yes Dennis yeah
so just classically there's people that
are working you know full-time and still
able to do properties so I think if
you've got the knowledge if you can
totally do it no matter what position
you're in I I believe anyway apply
yourself what's the best thing about
being a mom best thing about me
oh my gosh and the curdles like ran Ruby
does this random thing that way she'll
just come up to me she'll just cuddle me
and I'm like oh my gosh just thinking of
it oh I love kids
give me your hands you ever had a new
crying podcast
not exactly oh my give me your other
hand my kids are everything to me yes
sir so yeah okay okay the best thing
it's like a breathe honestly you you use
your son's be there will be in bed
together and you'll all be above thrown
on face because you begin your friend
you lose your quiet you'll get quite a
good look over and it'll be a picture of
like me and Ruby or something on me Luke
and they used I look over that you just
start crying with overwhelming joy I
think yes that's why I just think like
being a mom is awesome but I want to
inspire them in other ways and just like
I want them to look at me and be like oh
my gosh mom I'm so amazing like you know
it she was raising me but she was also
doing all of this and oh my gosh you
know when I was little my mom was
working on that project you know I think
you know so yeah I just want to inspire
them and being a mom is amazing I think
you're like the best role model to the
kids I'm just I'm not I'm not only am i
overwhelmed with joy that you're my wife
but I'm also everyone we joy that you're
the mother to our kids thank you because
you're just such a great example because
you're hard-working you're smart you're
loving I mean you just awesome and a lot
of fun
because because we are in some instances
you say family do some stuff but we also
like to party and stuff a little bit you
know we go a little bit crazy yeah you
know so
so we're back on air now with my softy
softy emotion emotional that gets I
don't know I think it's just because I
love them so much they bring me so much
joy yes just like insane how I don't
know they're my soft spot I guess yeah
do you reckon they make me melt
could you imagine love without kids and
I think yeah it's weird because we both
wanted kids I think even if we were just
together and it was just being you I do
love life and it'd be amazing but having
the kids yeah you happy person yeah are
you happy right now yes I'm so happy
with life you know I think you know you
you can choose to be happy well to a
certain extent you can choose to be
happier you create your own life and I
feel like the way that I lived my life
my ultimate goal in life you know this
is to be happy I'm not bothered about
other things like as long as I'm happy
that's what matters to me sir I make
sure that I live my life and do things
that make me happy yeah and I think I've
learned from you a lot is just enjoying
the moment because there's an
entrepreneur and as a business leader
you always looking forward to the future
you're planning planning planning making
it happen what what happen the goal but
actually sometimes just remembering that
right now because the future doesn't
exist and the past doesn't exist in one
sense the only thing that exists is
right now in this moment so you know
will often just take walks and be at the
park and I think just being in the
moment and although I'm not at home well
I'm at home quite a bit but like I
travel a lot
yes yeah but I feel like when I'm at
home at home yeah
you know and same with you when we're
talking even right now
you know it's just straight on in the
present yeah
is that something you can learn you can
learn can you learn to be depressed
right you've been told course is about
this yes I've been on courses about I've
attended an T one of t harv acres
programs it was called wizard camp
training camp and it was in Spain in the
name of the place but it's like what are
the tension the taught us about being
present being in the moment
should I go on the course I think you
could learn you could learn you know the
subtle way of saying get yo ass yeah I
think I think there's yeah I think
there's a few things that you could
learn it was it was interesting being
there it was a week of just being sort
of quieting you know quieting your mind
being present in the moment and yeah and
it was it was really good and it teaches
you how much did it cost me no you went
as well you went on TR because of the
course called Warrior Training Warrior
training camp in the light and Borya
enlightened warrior training camp yes
that was amazing I think I've just
learnt so much I've just just constantly
times I thought probably the same about
5,000 yeah what was the biggest thing
you took from Moria camp biggest thing I
took was that you know you don't have to
live to please anyone if you want to say
no to something just say no you don't
have to give a reason you know and be
true to yourselves almost as hard you
want to meet up for coffee tomorrow or
next week love them saying I'm busy no
you just don't want it yeah if you don't
want to just say I'll skip things yeah
you don't have to give a reason and also
the other biggest thing that I learned
from there was about eliminating the
word try so never saying that I'll try
to do this I'll try to do that no it's
not try you either choose to either
choose not
to try so think yeah so that was a
really big takeaway and if people say
even even I should really yeah shouldn't
say the word shirt
you shouldn't yeah you should not say
the word should is unlock yes I do not
know I do I go why because should they
said they were like saying that should
is like a words that you use to sort of
beat yourself so like if you like ah I
should have eaten a bit better there I
should have exercised or should do this
yes do it there yeah just do it because
you sort of like you just say I beating
yourself up over something that you
haven't done well just do it and then
don't think about you know why you
should do it but don't moan about have
you enjoyed going on my training
programmes yeah I have loved it
you've been on a lot of them I have yeah
and I went on a refresher of the DfE
dill funny extravaganza that was like
what's it like be it what's it like
being trained by me so me being on stage
or whatever and training and you've been
your my wife like how does that work I
don't know I love it I've always enjoyed
it because I love how you simplify
things and that was like one of the
things I remember when I attended you're
like one of your earlier training
courses the crash course and I'd never
i'd always I'd heard of property
investing but I'd never even thought it
was something that was accessible to me
I just thought oh yeah people do that
rich people do that and all cool you
know but actually going to your course I
remember leaving thinking oh my gosh
like I can actually do this it was just
so simplified so learning from you is
just like good and it's fun
so it's not just like boring and you
just sat there it's a PowerPoint it's
just like Oh kill me now it's does money
bring happiness mm-hmm I don't think it
brings happiness but I'm trying to think
of a grant I saw a post that Grant
Cardone did the other day and it said
something like money can't buy happiness
but poverty can't buy anything yeah that
was it that was it and I just thought
yes that's so true so don't think money
can buy happiness because I think I'd be
happy with or without but I think it
helps a lot that's fair yeah he doesn't
make you happy but it helps with it yeah
it helps with it I mean what's it like
I'm not being funny now people probably
hate for saying this but you know I got
a lot higher anyway yes you think he's
just no I don't I really don't I think
it's just you don't read it no I didn't
know that how do you deal with meetings
so in the spotlight I don't I don't read
any of the negative stuff I don't focus
any I don't pay any attention to stuff
like that you know the same wearing G
grain ichigo's energy flows yes and
focus goes yeah well first is and I
don't focus my I think focusing on like
negative stuff I just think people that
love to be negative about you or anyone
else I think it says a lot more about
them they obviously you trigger some
something in them that makes them feel
inferior for whatever reason and you
know they just like projecting their bad
feelings onto you mmm this is saying
you'll never be great by tearing someone
else down or you'll never you'll never
be great by making up making someone
else small something like that and I
just think people trying to make
themselves big by tearing someone else
down it's just an awful mentality and an
awful way to operate I just think it's
just ridiculous so how do I deal with it
I just don't focus my time just let them
deal with their own issues yeah how do
you do with jealous people I don't deal
with them so yeah
complete utter losers so I ask you the
question now if you're a loser listen if
you're a loser if you are a hater than
tune out now
yeah but I was going to ask Amanda
what's it like not having to ever look
at the price
to anything because I know that we live
our life I'm not being funny but you
ever got food we went out for dinner was
it last night the night before nice
dinner three courses had lots of friends
and stuff bike yeah and I said to Bill
you're like I don't know how I was like
I didn't look at just yes but but the
thing is that's the top 1% most people
cannot live life where they don't look
at the price tag they can go shopping
buy clothes they don't have to look at
the price tag is that weird it's not
weird
I think it's weird when I'm around
people that I used to be around before
now and we always been the same boat of
like oh my god looking at the menu
trying to think like or even planning
before we went out for a meal Oh what
shall we get you know and now when I'm
around people sometimes it's like ah
because I don't even think it's like oh
if I want something I'm just gonna have
it I'm on a menu or whatever throughout
so what was your question again what is
a strange now I'm used to it but I'm I
do right I do realize and always think
like oh my gosh you know cuz you could
you grateful that I'm in this position
what happened could you go back or could
you could if we didn't have money if we
lost everything which I don't think
we're on it I think that the way that I
am and you are like you could take all
my money and I'd get it back you know
and and and but at the same time if
everything did go it was forever reason
there was a massive massive recession
and we lost our properties and we lost
like how would you feel about going back
to five six seven years ago I mean I
just deal with it let's just deal with
it and try get better and build up you
know a super materialistic person yeah
you know you're not I like nice things
but you know and you know I'm a
suspender no I'm not you know I'm that
we I spawn probably a biggest better
than you are especially a holiday yeah
you love spending on experience well
when we go on holiday are literally just
sometimes we'll look at the hotels from
pricing and but you want but the reason
I do that is because I'm thinking I'm
probably only going to be in this
country won't ever and I want to
experience the best of this country and
I wanna have the best time and me having
a week off is very
and I want to absolutely maximize my
relaxation experience to the m50 grade
and and I think one of the reasons
sometimes people might hate on me being
so well do you be said well it's because
they think that it's come oh you're just
doing it because you're selling you have
people on how to get rich
it's like no we're not we don't we don't
even take a salary from the training
company we have a very successful
property company and we've worked bloody
hard to build that and it makes a lot of
money and I'm very proud and I'm very
happy and we're very generous yeah very
generous with family with we have a
charity yeah we've generous with the
knowledge generous with the money so I'm
just like yeah so when people hire
whatever yeah but really I need to stop
asking these questions because then
you'll start getting high anyway and I
don't want it so you would be fine with
it
yeah I'd be fine with it because just
ignore it move on
yeah and it's never real life like I
don't know one person apart from tenants
yeah tenants sometimes yeah tenants can
be crazy people as well yeah but we look
after attendance though we get Christmas
cards you're the best on whatever I mean
when they show the BBC show came out the
wheat the landlord's moved in weird a
lot of tenants like from blocks we just
messages to say just to say yeah even
though the show paid you a little bit
badly yeah whatever but they'll say
you're the best yes you know experience
is great as what they say and they yeah
they love biggest tips of property
investors biggest tip it sounds so
cliche but just read read educate
yourself you know socialise with
like-minded people yeah
because I think a lot of people negative
people be like oh my gosh you can't do
that can't do that that's not true but I
think when you're around people in the
environment with people that you know or
offer can-do attitude you can you can do
a lot and do a lot further but that's
what we do we only hang around
although and I'm not even talking rich
in finances sometimes we don't like we
hunger mcGarry's by our past though we
love him coming over I don't say these
poor poor but it's being rich is not
necessarily just about backbones it's it
like Marvin the personal my personal
trainer
you might know me really well for
financial aid yeah but it doesn't matter
your money does not define you it's
about people that are rich in mindset
that can do attitude yeah so I'm not a
snob but in terms of I don't wanna be
friends of people if they're poor
but I am very careful because I know the
bad company produces bad character yeah
and I know that your circle of friends
and your circle of influence has a
massive impact on you so I only want to
be around people that are successful
that are happy that are positive that I
can do looking forward to me failing
yeah I wanna be around people that
celebrating me succeeding yeah so we've
got the best friends I know yeah we've
got really good friends and even like at
the events you're at you know when I was
at the DfE I was like oh my gosh I
almost didn't want it to end you know
when you're in that just community with
everyone and it's just like good vibes
good energy like it's just amazing and I
think surrounding yourself with people
like that and being in that environment
of those people it's just it's so
important I think so yeah that'd be my
biggest tip get in a community with
people that are like-minded yeah I love
that well hey thanks for coming on the
show if you are listening to this on
Apple then please do subscribe and leave
a review if you're listening on YouTube
smash the light burn subscribe and let
us know in the comments what guests you
want if you want to see a man to come on
the show again I'd like to see a man do
on the show again then let us know and
thank you so much for listening and I
look forward to seeing you guys next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]